thumbs up for the next stage of TTIP the
world's most far-reaching trade deal
between the US and EU it's currently
under negotiation by the European
Commission but was heading nowhere after
it was pulled from the plenary agenda
earlier this month
amid reports of big differences within
the socialist group some plenum now
those differences particularly a clause
known as isds that would allow foreign
investors to sue governments if their
interests are threatened and narrowing
I'm cautiously optimistic it's important
to replace the existing isds if this
will happen then it's fundamental
European the United States to design the
new rules on global trade and investment
sooner the better to pass this
resolution because this way the
Commission we have a stronger mandate to
negotiate with the US across Europe
views on TTIP are becoming more
polarized supporters say it will help
build a new era of prosperity and jobs
in the US and EU opponents say it'll
strengthen multinationals at the expense
of small businesses the next negotiating
round is due in Brussels in July
you